all right let's cover a couple of other
things in the limited time we have left
today uh thanks to that uh
wacky and uh long interview with mike
pillow my my pillow founder mike lindell
uh we've been wondering you know sort of
like what is going to happen
depending on what does or doesn't happen
in august or september of course there's
going to be no reinstatement of donald
trump
we are starting to get some data points
that they are planning
something and i have one video to look
at here with you today this
is um an amaga organizer named matt
brainard affiliated with an organization
called look ahead america he was on with
steve bannon and
seems to be saying that september 18th
is going to be a date on which they are
going back to the capital of course the
capital being the place where the trump
riots took place
so let's listen to that i'm actually
going to make some news on your show
today
we have our next rally planned it's in
the middle of september september 18th
and it's going to be huge and what's
going to define it is where it's going
to take place
right we're going back to the capitol so
understand
whether you consider this an overt or a
more
sort of implicit signal about what
they're talking about he's saying
we're going to redo january 6. now to
what extent it's going to be redone
we don't yet know right where it started
on september 18th
and we're going to push back against the
phony narrative that there was an
insurrection
we're going to provide the kind of
evidence that nancy pelosi won't allow
to be presented at her select committee
showing that this was a largely peaceful
crowd showing that this was a crowd that
was egged on in many ways by capitol
police throwing flash
flashbang grenades into a relatively
peaceful crowd
relatively peaceful is an interesting
way to describe it relative to what
we're going to present the evidence that
ashley babbitt's death should be
investigated
we're going to demand now now remember
ashley babbitt's death was investigated
it was investigated we have a full
report about it release of 14
000 hours of videotape that the the
federal government has been suppressing
that's another one of these where we we
we
have even if you grant that not every
minute
of video has been released we already
have hours and hours and hours and hours
and hours of video
and so the idea that only the video
that's being kept
secret as they claim is what would
change our entire perception of what
took place
that's another false narrative that
they're pushing so we're going right
back to the capitol because we're not
afraid
and we're going to press our case and i
believe that at that we're going to have
some very
high profile speakers there we're going
to have members of congress speak
we're going to continue to raise the
volume and push back against this phony
narrative
and demand justice for these political
prisoners justice for political
prisoners can you imagine
so if you check out um the website for
this organization look ahead america
they said they've announced their next
rally it's called justice for
j6 if you can imagine something more
depraved
and they say it will be at the capitol
on september 18th
at noon so much reason to be worried and
hopefully this is something that law
enforcement is paying attention to
we'll talk about that a little bit more
tomorrow